We mentioned this several times,
but the SW in the resource folder name
stands for smallest width.
To drive home that point,
let's walk through
a hypothetical situation.
Say you have an app
directory structure like this.
We have some layouts defined
in the base layout folder,
and we override some of those
in the layout-sw600dp folder.
We also override one of these
in the layout-sw720dp folder.
Let's look at which layouts
would be applied on which device.
Say your app is running on a Nexxus 5.
The Nexxus 5 has dimensions
360dp x 640dp.
Of the two, the smallest width is 360dp.
So we use this number to compare it
against the folder names.
360dp is less than 600
and is less than 720,
so all the layouts will come
from the space layout folder.
For the Nexus 7 2012 version,
the dimensions are 600dp x 960dp.
Of the two sides
600dp is the smaller width.
So you compare this
against the folder names.
It turns out that the smallest width
is better than or equal to 600dp,
so for the detail and the item layouts,
we pull it from this folder.
Now the main.xml file
is not declared in this folder,
so we fall back to a less specific folder,
which turns out to be this one
in the base layout folder.
For the Nexus 10 the dimensions
are 800dp x 1280dp.
Of the two sides,
800dp is the smallest width.
Now this device satisfies
the categories for all of these
because 800 is greater than 720
and greater than 600.
However, the system chooses
the most specific folder first.
So it will choose this item layout
over these two.
Since the detail layout
is not defined here,
it will fall back to a less
specific folder, which is this one.
Then for the main.xml file,
it's not declared in either of these,
so it falls back to this one.